Rick Neuheisel was at the Rose Bowl the
former college coach now working for CBS
leads us off 2018 coach thanks for
joining us welcome to program how was
last night's atmosphere well I I know
I'm biased with the granddaddy of Malden
and happy New Year to you and your boys
but I might have watched it's one of the
best college football games of all time
given the magnitude of the moment given
the stage and given the first ever
overtime game in Rose Bowl history and
winner going on to play for the national
championship it was everything you could
ever have want to to take in on a
January first college football event it
was awesome football give me the logic
here with what Oklahoma was doing at the
end with their play calling that they
weren't letting or relying on Baker
Mayfield to make place why that was
strange
it was absolutely strange to see what
was transpiring there to get in overtime
and and handoff three times and take the
ball out of the - Trophy winners hands
and and then in the second overtime you
know sit there and look like you're
gonna go for it on fourth down again
with the best player in college football
standing there ready to make a play for
you but you know given what was going on
given all that was transpiring given the
amount of experience that Lincoln
Rockies had I guess I understand I
really do understand but if you could go
back and play rewind I think he'd make
some different decisions what did you
take away from that game with Baker
Mayfield you know I thought it was not
his best 23 or 35 you know that
certainly in the beginning of the game
when Georgia was playing more zone he
was taking advantage when they jumped
into some more man in the second half it
complicated things for him and obviously
the length of Georgia's pass rush also
made him take some moments where he lost
vision on the field it was not vintage
Mayfield but certainly when you look at
the numbers for 54 48
you got to say somebody was doing some
good things on offense okay but if you
look at him as we move this forward as
we love to do with with these
quarterbacks those who played in bowl
games Josh Rosen didn't but handicap
these four and how you think the NFL
will assess them I think coming out of
it
and Arnold didn't win but I thought
Donald played pretty darn heroically
given the pass rush that was after him
you know on every down basis I think
darn 'old and Rosen are right there and
it's gonna be determined by the brass
that has those early choices I think you
know Rosen's concussion history is going
to probably weigh against him so I'm
gonna clean darn 'old we'll go one Rosen
will go to I think Alan probably sits
there and gets somebody to just fall in
love with him because of the carson
wentz in Craig Bohl relationship and
he's like this guy I think that's three
and and Baker
he slides to the middle too late first
round now with this game under his belt
do you really believe Josh Rosen doesn't
want to play for Cleveland I really
believe that he's smart enough to be
listening to people and blah blah blah
but I think somebody is is let me say
this I think Josh Rose is gonna put his
hat in and say he's all in I think he's
gonna realize you know he can't sit and
play that kind of game what but but you
know this kid you're like the
personality and you wondered a couple of
weeks ago you know does he really like
how much does he really want this you
know that that when you're down you're
you're you know playing for a losing
team is it there he's gonna have a deep
within him does it sound like that would
be something he would say
of all of these quarterbacks we thought
Rosen would be the one guy who might say
something like that but I just don't
want to play for that organization well
like I said he's he's different than
most kids that are entering an NFL Draft
given his background given you know the
environment that he grew up in with with
you know wealth and you know money was
not ever really important to him so
these decisions
him I think are going to be more than
just financial but I do believe at day's
end he's just gonna say hey look I just
want to play I want to go and and become
part of our organization say all the
same things that all the other guys are
going to say the question is are they
going to trust him he's Rick Neuheisel
CBS college football analyst joining us
Continental Tire Coach's Corner
Baker Mayfield's personality the pros
and cons on how the NFL will look at
this is that personality a positive or
negative to you I think it will be
perceived positively because somebody
who's going to take him is going to say
I want that fire I always calm the fire
by you know dousing it maybe the flames
somewhat and it's better to do that than
trying to artificially cajole and in
stoke a fire this guy burns he's got as
he told me in New York got a boulder on
his shoulder not a chip I think the team
that decides Baker Mayfield's their next
guy is going to be excited about that
Alabama's defense is Georgia better
equipped to attack it or would Oklahoma
have been better equipped I think
Oklahoma would have been better equipped
you know Alabama will will play against
this you know one-two punch of Chubb and
Michele better than anybody can play it
maybe Clemson would have done that as
well but but Alabama looked back to full
speed on defense last night holding
Clemson to 181 that that was that was
that was vintage Crimson Tide football
and given you know what Georgia likes to
do and I know they do it really well
with both Michelle and Chubb averaging
more than 10 yards a carry yesterday I
just think Alabama's best suited to
handle that kind of one-two punch I I
don't normally look at this you know
with a conspiracy conspiracy theorist
angle but I can't help but think Alabama
being favored last night against Clemson
they'll be favored probably against
Georgia how can you assess this if
you're the committee and say they're the
fourth best team in the country when
everybody else looks at them differently
well you're right I mean at the end of
the day it comes down to what we've been
used to over the BCS era right if you
lose late you have to go to the end of
the line and fortunately Alabama there
were enough people in the room that said
hey look if they just lost a burn at
Auburn and everybody believed Auburn was
a top team in the country at the time
and you look at Ohio State I know they
were the Big Ten champs and now we have
this bowl resume from the Big Ten that
had they had that probably Alabama
wouldn't have made it but but the bottom
line is they did have that that Iowa
loss to ponder by the Buckeyes and so
fortunately for Alabama there was enough
to keep him in the deal but the truth of
the matter is they all knew and
especially the coaches in that room knew
Alabama was as good a football team as
there was they were just done you know
can some bald tires at the season's end
yeah I still think Ohio State's one of
the top four teams Oklahoma in there as
well the Central Florida win against
Auburn III hope people noticed it
because that you know that's one of
those you go oh by the way they just
beat Auburn what did you take away from
Central Florida this year well it was a
remarkable story and somewhere down the
line I hope we remember what makes March
Madness so special is that Cinderella
story and you know I go back a couple
years when Tom Herman and Greg Ward jr.
at Houston you know kind of shocked the
world by beating Florida State and
starting the next season by beating
Oklahoma and you know having big wins
along the way as a group of five team
taking on the big mighty power five I
would love to see the group of five
choice by the committee always be a part
of a playoff and hopefully somewhere
down the road we can get that done you
know what do you mean by that
I mean we got to add more teams but how
many how many do we have because my
perfect scenario then would be twelve I
think we have such a cross-section of
what we do for a football season and
what makes economic sense in all these
athletic departments I would like to see
all the power five teams be able to put
two
teens in you decide as a conference how
many conference games you want to play
you decide what works best for you in
determining who your best two teams are
but two teams and that would give us ten
a group of five representative and this
year it would have been a UCF and then a
at large and we'll have for the top four
teams as determined by the committee
they get it by the next eight play we
can find a way to do away with the
comfort of the conference championship
games let the conference's determine how
they're going to determine their
champions in another way but take away
that 13th game so that we can have it be
in a quarterfinal type of setting and
away we go
how much would you like to see Wisconsin
play again how much would you like to
see Ohio State play again Penn State's
victory over Washington was spectacular
love to see that one more game and we're
just warming up right now we saw some
great football it's it's we're going to
be excited about what happens in Atlanta
next Monday but ultimately I think some
more football would be fun to watch yeah
I think we had the playoffs in the final
month of the regular season Rick I I
just think that if you go to 12 then
what stops you from going to 14 or 16 or
18 that's what makes me nervous
I know the four is not perfect it's
better than the BCS you know if you
expand a six okay but I know that you
know we never stop it's like once you
open the door then that's it we're done
March Madness is diluted if you don't
make March Madness you should be fired
[Laughter]
you you make some good points I I'm not
arguing holy and if we could be you and
I could sit down and do the schedule in
the last month the November portion of
the season and we could put the the
matchups together on the field I would
agree but when Alabama's playing Mercer
in November and we have those kind of
games in as calculated scheduling
decisions so that I can put myself in
best position then I sit there and I say
okay why isn't the pac-10 able to do
that or the pac-12 able to do that and
the reason they're not able to do that
is they can't financially afford to pay
a million and a half a million eight to
a Mercer to
in play they have to make different
kinds of decisions and when that's the
case then we've got a little bit of an
unfair playing field which has always
been the case in college I'm saying why
can't we make it a little bit more fair
so that all portions of the country feel
some measure of representation always
great to talk to you
Thank You Rick we appreciate it Happy
New Year Happy New Year Rick that's Rick
Neuheisel CBS college football analyst
Continental Tire Coaches Corner
from Sunday rain to snow and everything
in between cut no no tires engineer tire
for what you do extraordinary
performance and reliability putting
confidence into driving for more
information and the location of a dealer
near you visit Continental Tire calm cut
a little tire for what you do for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]